- My goal is to get
every single single woman
carrying around condoms
just as they carry around everything else.
It's like a no brainer
and I always joke, like, "How do we get people
to take selfies with condoms?"
I'm Meika Hollender, and I'm
the co-founder of Sustain,
which is a brand of all natural
sexual wellness products
marketed to women.
Only 19% of single sexually active women
use condoms regularly.
And one in four college freshmen
actually gets an STD during
her first year at school.
And this is a crisis and this is a subject
that isn't being talked about
because, when you think
about condoms and lubricant,
these are products that
can be seen as taboo.
Women are extremely uncomfortable
buying and carrying condoms.
When I go to my peers and
the people that I know,
they're the worst offenders.
We're trying to rebrand it a little bit
and completely empower women to
take control of their sexual health
with much better products.
Most lubricants out there
contain parabens and glycerin
and petroleum and silicone.
Our products have none of those things.
They're aloe and water-based.
It's the only fair trade certified
carcinogen-free condom
on the market in the U.S.
We are starting a conversation
that needs to be had.
So, I spend a lot of
time talking to consumers
about why they not only need
to be using our products,
but also why they should be
just using condoms in general.
You should never feel ashamed
for wanting to or having sex.
But, the reality is,
you're out there for you
and you need to protect yourself.
Nobody else is going to.